muchos estudiantes quieren saber qué se
consume en un foco incandescente cuando
está en serie con una resistencia
corriente energía o ambas a ellos se les
ocurren dos preguntas en un segundo
salen menos electrones de los que entran
al foco cambia la energía potencial de
los electrones mientras se encuentran
dentro del foco la primera pregunta
tiene que ver con la medida de corriente
la corriente es cuánta carga por segundo
pasa en cierta parte de nuestro circuito
así que la carga por segundo también
podemos pensarla como electrones por
segundo entonces usaremos la corriente
para responder a la primera pregunta y
la energía potencial eléctrica de los
electrones es el cambio en el voltaje o
caída de voltaje cuando pasamos de un
lado a otro en el circuito los
estudiantes tienen una fuente de energía
ajustable cable cubierto resistencias
interruptores voltímetro amperímetro y
otro equipo estándar de laboratorio
supón que la fuente de energía y el
voltímetro están marcados con
incrementos de décimas de volts y el
amperímetro tiene incrementos de
centésimas de amperes describe el
procedimiento experimental que puede
realizarse para responder a las
preguntas 1 y 2 en su descripción indica
las medidas que realizar y as y cómo
usarías el equipo para realizar las
incluye un diagrama de tu configuración
incluye etiquetas para cada elemento
vamos a resolver este primer inciso aquí
abajo vamos a dibujar nuestra fuente de
poder que si mal no recuerdo nos dijeron
es ajustable muchos estudiantes quieren
saber qué se consume en un foco
incandescente cuando está en serie con
una resistencia vamos a tratar de
dibujar esto vamos a dibujar solamente
el circuito sin ningún aparato tiene una
fuente de poder variable
así lo dibujamos esta es la terminal
positiva y esta es la negativa y ahora
dibujamos el resto del circuito sin
ningún aparato de medición aún así que
esto lo ponemos en serie con una
resistencia continuamos dibujando el
circuito y aquí ponemos nuestro foco
incandescente hay varios símbolos para
representar esto pero yo lo voy a
dibujar así una curva continua a la que
después le dibujar un círculo alrededor
y termino de dibujar el circuito lo
mejor que puedo ya que nos piden un
diagrama de nuestra configuración aquí
tenemos nuestro foco incandescente aquí
está nuestra fuente de poder y para
indicar que es una fuente variable le
pongo una flecha diagonal encima este es
el circuito que acabo de configurar pero
quiero usar voltímetros y amperímetro
para poder medir lo que ocurre con
nuestros electrones cuando pasan por el
foco la convención es dibujar la
corriente que sale de la terminal
positiva y que va hacia la terminal
negativa pero nosotros sabemos y si no
lo saben los invito a que vean los
vídeos que tenemos en casa de mí
respecto que lo que ocurre realmente es
que los electrones salen de la terminal
negativa hacia la terminal positiva pero
en general cuando hablamos de corriente
denotamos que la convención es dibujar
la corriente saliendo de la terminal
positiva hacia la terminal negativa
aunque sabemos que los electrones viajan
en el sentido opuesto la primera
pregunta es tenemos diferente cantidad
de electrones antes de que entren al
foco comparado con la cantidad de
electrones que salen del foco la forma
en que podemos medir esto es tomar la
corriente en ambos lados del foco y la
forma de hacer esto es insertar
amperímetro en serie a cada lado del
foco hacemos espacio para insertar
nuestros amperímetro aquí tenemos un
amperímetro para medir la corriente de
este lado le ponemos una y por este otro
lado ponemos otro amperímetro con esto
vamos a medir la corriente a ambos lados
del foco
así que estos miden la corriente que
entra y sale del foco y también nos
interesa la caída de voltaje por lo que
vamos a poner un voltímetro y lo vamos a
poner en paralelo con el foco así que
vamos a dibujar el voltímetro para que
así lo dibujamos y lo vamos a usar para
medir la caída de voltaje de un lado del
foco al otro así que esto mide la caída
de voltaje aquí ya tenemos nuestro
diagrama quien más tenemos que hacer nos
dice describe el procedimiento
experimental que puede realizarse para
responder a las preguntas 1 y 2 en su
descripción indica las medidas que
realizar y as y cómo usar y asia el
equipo para realizar las incluye un
diagrama de tu configuración incluye
etiquetas para cada elemento así que mi
descripción es colocar
a perímetros en serie con el foco 1
antes del foco 1 antes del foco y otro
después del foco si tenemos la misma
corriente en ambos lados entonces quiere
decir que hay la misma cantidad de
electrones que entran y salen del foco
así que si la corriente es
la misma en ambos lados entonces
tendremos la misma cantidad la misma
cantidad de electrones por segundo que
entran y salen
si las corrientes si las corrientes son
diferentes entonces la tasa de
electrones
que pasan
es diferente aquí tenemos el primer
enunciado que nos piden en un segundo
salen menos electrones de los que entran
al foco si los amperímetro se miden en
la misma corriente entonces tendremos la
misma cantidad de electrones por segundo
que entran y salen del foco si los
amperímetro tienen mediciones diferentes
entonces tendremos diferentes cantidades
de electrones ahora para el enunciado 2
ponemos que esto es para el enunciado 1
es la prueba del enunciado 1
este es mi procedimiento
para el enunciado 2 prueba del enunciado
2 creo que ustedes saben a qué me
refiero pero lo escribo de todas maneras
porque ustedes tendrán que hacerlo si
realizan este examen así que aquí
escribo colocar voltímetro en paralelo
con el foco si mide una caída de voltaje
entonces
como dice el enunciado cambia la energía
potencial de los electrones mientras se
encuentran dentro del foco entonces la
energía potencial de los electrones
cambia normalmente no escribo tanto de
otra manera esto no ocurre así que
escribo si no hay caída de voltaje
entonces no cambia la energía potencial
eléctrica
y listo ya tenemos el inciso a dibujar
un diagrama con claridad midiendo la
corriente que entra y que sale del foco
si vemos esto desde el punto de vista de
los electrones los electrones entran por
la derecha y salen por la izquierda de
cualquier manera los electrones por
segundo afectan a la corriente si la
corriente es la misma tendremos la misma
cantidad de electrones por segundo y si
la corriente es diferente entonces
tendremos diferente cantidad de
electrones por segundo que entran y
salen del foco y esto mide la energía
potencial eléctrica a través del foco si
medimos un voltaje aquí entonces
significa que está cambiando la energía
potencial eléctrica de un lado del foco
al otro me voy a detener aquí y creo que
ya respondí parte del inciso b también
bueno de hecho respondí todo el inciso b
explica como la información obtenida con
el experimento que describes puede
usarse para responder la pregunta 1 y
explica cómo la información obtenida en
el experimento que describes puede
usarse para responder la pregunta 2
así que ya resolvimos los incisos a yb
vamos a escribirlo esto es a y ve aquí
tenemos el diagrama si ustedes están
resolviendo este examen y tienen algo de
tiempo pueden poner más etiquetas a este
diagrama pero si tienen poco tiempo
pueden dejarlo así y evitar poner mucho
detalle